- Une cérémonie pourrtrtrtrtrtr,
et même du sommet.
Le président Biden présente
la Déclaration de AnAnAngeles
sur la migration visant à revoir
la gestion des flux migratoires
exemple, s'engage à accroîtreson
des réfugiés des Amériques
4000 personnes d'ici 2028.
Mais des absents sur cette
photo de famille portent
déclaration. Joe Biden estimait
que les régimes du Venezuela,
du Nicaragua et de Cuba ne
Le président mexicain a décidé
de bouder la rencontre.
Or, ces pays sont à l'origine
d'importants flux migratoires.
- C'est la grande faiblesse,
- Mais les États-Unis n'avaient
pas l'intention pour autant
d'abandonner cette idée
MARIE-CHRISTINE DORAN, prof.,
École études polit., U.aaaaa
- Leur stratégie, c'est
d'essayer de négocier
des adhésions en ce mosssssssssr
de sauver un peu la mise.
- Justin Trudeau a cherché à
se tenir loitetetetetetetetetets
même s'il signale son
attachemprprprprprincipes
démocratiques.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
- Le Canada est déterminé à
travailler avec ses partenaires
pour améliorer la résilience
de nos démocraties.
- Si le gouvernement Trudeau dit
avec les pays d'Amérique, si le
premie a a a a a a multiplié les
rencontres, il a aussi réservé
du temps pour son principal
En plus de son entretien avec
le président Joe Biden, il a
aussi discuté avec la présidente
Nancy Pelosi.
Le r r r r r r r r r r r r r rs
que d'autres pays d'Amérique
en raison de sa géographie.
Le gouvernement Trudeau souhaite
l'entente sur les tiers pays
sûrs qui permet les milliers
de passages au chemin Roxham.
Des pourparlers durent depuis
l'urgence, c'est peut-être
justement parce que ces en
irrégulières représentent
une goutte d'eau par rapport
ailleurs sur le continent.
Ici Madeleine Blais-Morin,
Radio-Canada, Los Angeles.